[Music]
[Music]
who you for you who's she how are you
guys having what the hell
you know Spencer was this
Bunji you pick a character and then
you're that person in the game should we
play
[Applause]
oh my god fridge yeah I'm fridge who are
you
me Spencer Martha yeah
I think we got sucked into the game and
we've all become the avatars we chose so
that means Bethany
[Applause]
I'm an overweight middle-aged man this
can't actually be happening guys how are
we gonna get home this is a video game
which means we all have special skills
[Music]
strengths peerless speed smoldering
intensity damn that is a man right there
I hate this game we don't want to get
stuck in Jumanji we have to help each
other ladies we're all watched metal fan
machine go safer I'm not getting in
there okay I'm still an old fat guy
right
I'm afraid so I have to warn you I think
I'm a very strong puncher
[Music]
what is it
now let this new body get your butt
whooped I'd like to see you try you guys
it's no way that's good news
oh right oh right nose
a huge white stereo stupidly a people
let's never start the bottling me a
little bit
[Music]
as a black mamba okay trust one another
and never blink never blink huh you guys
I think it's a staring contest it's
talking about think about it never blink
guys who's good at staring and not
blinking I'm amazing at it then this is
your moment
just say when
[Music]
need you to follow me and do exactly as
I say
let's move oh my god you guys I am so
stoked you are here you have no idea you
are so stoked
Thanks against the wall this game sucks
watch your step in here
stay off the white bricks what what is
going on we got sucked into the game and
we've become the avatars we chose
where's my hair
I have a tattoo where's the rest of me
I look like a living garden um where is
my phone we have to work together
don't let this new body get your butt
whooped Jumanji in 3d and RealD 3d we
want to make a movie that capsule eights
what the holiday spirit really means the
spirit of wonderment discovering who you
are oh wait I have such a tremendous
amount of love and reverence for the
original movie and what Robin meant to
my family I loved it like the world
loved it we want to make sure that the
spirit of the original movie flowed
through his continuation of the Jumanji
story
[Music]
seeing any type of game that you got oh
my god what is this I want to play my
curiosity is what got us in the game you
know what's this this is a game it will
always find a way to be playing a game
for those who seek to find a way to
leave their world behind Jumanji
before high school kids that are in
detention they get sucked into the
jungles of Jumanji the original Jumanji
came to our world and this Jumanji we go
to that
where's the rest of me get in the game
Fritz me Spencer kids are now the avatar
so that means I'm Bethany Bethany
Bethany I'm an overweight middle-aged
now
the game is survival stakes are very
high I was so intense I like can't even
with this place most wonderful awesome
badass character I've ever played I have
to warn you I think I'm a very strong
puncher this film is is packed full of
amazing action sequences that makes me
look really cool
- so many moments that look big laughs
and frankly there's a man right there
don't cry don't cry don't cry it's gonna
be okay Jumanji
maybe we're all in a coma
what no game machine you don't get water
with it back back everybody knows that
fridge who used me Spencer MRSA somehow
we got sucked into two mangy we become
the avatars who chose Bethany this is a
video game we all have special skills
speed is my weakness rather die on my
back no I'm going down Jumanji
[Music]
what is going on we got sucked into
Jumanji where's my hair why am i wearing
short shorts in the jungle
I don't have a job to say to my body
I'm an overweight middle-aged man
you get in there say you get in there
you get water with it back back
everybody knows that Jumanji
in 3d and real t3d fun group welcome to
detention Spencer
Bethany fridge Martha you're all here
for a reason you know what it is you
should be thinking about who you are and
who you want to be fortunately you'll
have plenty of time to figure that out
while you're cleaning out the basement
that yeah
it's mystery is this Jumanji a game for
those who seek to find a way to leave
their world behind where are those
avatar names so you pick a character and
then you're that person in the game so
I'm real quick I don't think it matters
that much should be play
[Music]
they wear the rest of me oh my god
bridge damn fridge who are you it's me
Spencer who is she
think we got sucked into the game and
we've all become the avatars with chills
so that means I'm Bethany Bethany
Bethany I'm an overweight middle-aged
man
welcome to Jumanji
Wow
I have to warn you I think I'm a very
strong puncher
don't cry don't cry don't cry it's gonna
be okay all right
[Music]